the bitcoin king michael saylor has
bought more bitcoin that's right this
morning michael saylor tweeted out that
microstrategy has bought 660 more
bitcoin for approximately 25 million
dollars in cash the average price coming
in at 37 865 per bitcoin as of the end
of january they now have more than 125
000 bitcoin which they have spent about
3.78 billion dollars at an average price
of about 30 000
pretty incredible to see the absolute
focus and the fanatical pursuit of
acquiring more bitcoin over time
microstrategy started out with zero
bitcoin just two years ago and now they
have over 125 000 bitcoin what's
fascinating to me though is this is not
just a micro strategy bet michael saylor
personally has skin in the game as well
he reportedly owns just under 18 000
bitcoin as well at 38 000 his personal
bitcoin is worth about 673
million dollars he says that he bought
it around nine thousand dollars and that
personal cost base was about 175 million
dollars pretty incredible to watch the
ceo the founder one of the longest
standing public company ceos both be
personally invested and also doing it
professionally he tweeted back in
october 28 of 2020 and said that he had
bought 17 732 bitcoin at about 9 82
on average now this is important because
what we are watching is microstrategy
the first public company to go ahead and
put bitcoin on their balance sheet and
then michael saylor going around not
only trying to help other executives
understand why he's doing it and how he
did it but he continues to spend time
educating both the public and the
executive ranks we've seen him go on
national television we've seen him do
every podcast under the sun and we've
also seen him host conferences where he
says i will open source the playbook of
how you as a corporation or an
institutional investor can do the same
exact thing that i've been doing now
michael saylor and microstrategy they
have two strategies at the business they
run their software company their
analytics and what they do is they try
to drive as much cash flow as they
possibly can at the same time they have
a balance sheet strategy which they
continue to try to acquire as much
bitcoin as they possibly can as well and
so when you have somebody who
understands we are running a software
business that drives financial
performance and then we are going to
convert that fiat currency into a strong
digital decentralized digital asset like
bitcoin i think it ends up being pretty
incredible now one of the things that
people always ask is as michael saylor
continues to dollar cost average into
bitcoin these are big boy purchases 25
million dollars or more at a time but he
recently was on up only tv where he told
kobe he said i'm gonna always be buying
all-time highs sometimes i'll be buying
lows as well but i'm just continuing to
dollar cost average i don't give a [ __ ]
what the price of bitcoin is all i
continue to do is try to acquire more of
it i think that is a lesson in there for
many people michael saylor the bitcoin
king he continues to acquire as much
bitcoin as he possibly can so far so
good for him microstrategy and also the
millions of shareholders across the
world who are all watching in awe as
michael saylor conducts one of the most
high conviction trades in wall street
history